nothing was bad you're making it out
like it's bad can i tell you
i have a question i have i have a
genuine question what are your thoughts
on people who say they skate
but are actual posers in real life okay
okay all right dude
or i'll stop stop for a second or stop
for a second all right and just just
push positive who cares i don't know
where i don't know where you're okay
i don't
but don't know how to skate
okay that's an attack on me i was gonna
say that seems a very pointed question
you own a skate show it's oddly specific
okay so
right
i i used to live in silver lake yeah and
me and my friend opened up a skate store
called juve
juvie
in silver lake right
and i my best friend at the time was a
guy named laven fighters you know who he
is right so laban you know
was a skater for dog town and he for a
couple years and a prolific juggler he's
one of the best jugglers and he can do
that little he's a you know michael
yeah he's a freaky white dude where he
can do all that yeah damn oh yeah yeah
you're like you know how freaky white
dudes can do all that with the fire he
performed he performed at riley's uh
birthday party like his third or fourth
birthday party no yeah because i mean i
didn't have money to
get animals and whatnot or
experiences and so he came and juggled
yeah and people were hyped oh he's good
he's not good babe what's that i used to
live with him yeah yeah with laban in
silver lake nice in ca in encinitas oh
really back in the day when he was just
a pro skateboarder i love him and he
would he told me how to juggle
wow yeah
what he's one of the greatest guys of
all time [ __ ] talent okay so but you
try to teach me how to do it right wow
wait a minute juggling or ollying what's
going on
you know what
oh you're [ __ ] rude tony it looks
like the horse was trying to buck him
off
oh you guys went mechanical balls i get
it now
and juggled at the same time all right
i should have demonstrated it but
basically what i'm trying to do is lift
yeah right
yeah bring something down and go
don't do that again i'm gonna do the
demonstration don't do a hee-haw or
anything like that please all right so
here i go i do a cut click do it do it
again jason
do it again jason
yeah
all right
so yeah and i just couldn't do it
i never learned how yeah back to the
story about the show we could help you
skateboarding skills though well i got a
skateboard in the car we don't get you
there we get you there there is no way
you could only right now i can
definitely get you to ollie yeah you can
teach me at all in five minutes yes
there's no way you can i i dude
guaranteed but guaranteed video of you
doing an ollie the board's in the air
and you landed back on the board yeah
guaranteed
it doesn't work without a skateboard
let's see how bad it is that's not bad
okay it's not bad you're just it's slow
see you're gonna get a pop yeah there's
there's a there's a snap that's closer
that's it yeah and he looked at us while
he was doing it yeah that's how easy he
could do it eye contact you have no
under that hurts so [ __ ] bad on where
there's everywhere my ankles two knee
joints i'm [ __ ] there's no way i'm
going to learn oh and i'm old i'm 50 now
i'm 50. we just got your timing better
that's right you're right
i did learn i did grow a little bit
you're no longer a poser sweetie
congratulations no you know what
she then called me out hold on leave it
out there leave it out there you called
me out right but since i love you
and since i love you and since we're
lovers
put it here
sorry man yeah but i've never reconciled
my wife like that yeah i don't put her
here
i'm not gonna well i love you and we're
lovers and put her here
okay pal
you're probably also next i'll see you
tonight you probably also never lied to
her about being a good skater
wait you said you were good yes when we
first met yeah
how good did you say it
all over his home oh
oh you were like claiming yes
[Laughter]
bobby you started i understand that
right
but does this count wow i know
personally
probably a hundred str like pro skaters
just listen here might let me just
defend myself all right
including news yes i could tell yeah
yeah thank you and i um
i also have i grew up in san diego so i
grew up in the environment of it right
and um so i understand the culture i
understand the sport like i understand
the history of it yeah you're obsessed
with it yeah yeah i'm obsessed you know
i'm obsessed with you right yeah i'm
obsessed with it his brother is also a
great skateboarder my brother can ali
and
flip he'll flip he can do a pop shove it
all that kind of stuff but um
yeah i don't know how but anyway let's
move on okay i don't want him anymore i
am a [ __ ] poser you know what i'm not
you know what [ __ ] it i'm a poser
i'm a loser and i'm a poser can you roll
on one
can you roll down the road on a
skateboard
i was just trying to i'm trying to lead
you into a good thing here if you can
okay then you can skate hey [ __ ] tardy
i never had anybody yeah [ __ ] heart
that small say that
it doesn't feel good doesn't it it
doesn't feel good doesn't it
feel good you're coming across crazy
i'm sorry you're right you're wrong i
never had anyone say that they couldn't
back it up
yeah you're right i can't back up my
back
i was too aggressive but can i just say
that
let's calm down let's get back forget he
also fights a mma i get it let's just go
back to you know
let's go back a little bit and i want to
say the reason why i called you that
was because i felt like earlier i was
trying to um
make you feel better about your life and
whatnot yeah i said also about no just
listen to what i'm saying okay
all right and i was unnecessarily
granted right and i was just remembering
all that stuff like you're there with
the other canadians so you belong i was
trying to do all that yeah and then you
did that and then you showed your
vulnerability that's right he didn't
back and he did not back me up on thank
you so much tony i understand
i understand what he's saying i don't
think it deserved [ __ ] hard
okay but i understand okay i think flood
card was too harsh i think yeah yeah
twice i did it twice i apologize yeah
all right can we forget that that
incident ever happened all right can we
move on yeah thank you
let me let's just let's let's just i
want to take a little temperature of the
room we should roll down the hill
together
we have great hills here bro hates it
you know what i am going to prove to you
once and for all i am a [ __ ] up i can
[ __ ] roll down a [ __ ] i'm not
saying you can't
i'm asking if you want to but yeah
he wasn't challenging oh asking oh i
took it the wrong way he did you're so
defensive oh i was so i took it the
wrong way you were asking this is what
you're doing you were going hey bob why
don't we roll down the sale together
yeah you don't need to that's not what i
heard what i heard was i bet you you
can't [ __ ] roll down the hill
right so i apologize it might have been
a bit of both it was a little too a step
too far
and let's read the temperature of the
room let me ask you two okay because you
don't know me that well all right
from one to ten how much do you like me
and i like you a lot
so far so far so far i i i think that
they're an accidental likeable genius
because you're kind of mean to people
and you kind of backstab and say
things that are like mean and
inappropriate but you're like
you got